when can I go to the stars one day by
sweet what will be there anything you
can imagine our galaxy has billions of
stars each of those stars could have
many worlds every world could be home to
a different form of life and every life
is a special story of its own these
words spoken by astronaut Buzz Aldrin
and Mass Effect 3 post-credits team
encapsulate what I think makes science
fiction so great it's the idea that our
storytelling is limited only by the
reach of our imagination
the notion that there will always be
room for one more myth or one more
legend in places far far away the
characters of the Mass Effect trilogy
have become such icon their saga has
elevated them above video game stardom
they've transcended the medium and
become part of a wider pop culture but
now Mass Effect Andromeda is in our
hands it takes us to a whole new galaxy
and presents us with another world of
storytelling potential but it squandered
that potential viewed through the wider
scope of science fiction
Andromeda is a giant leap in the wrong
direction
[Music]
you
for as long as we've been around humans
have told stories there on the cave
walls of modern-day France they covered
papyrus in the Library of Alexandria
they've been passed down from generation
to generation around campfires and
dinner tables morphing with each new
telling and look also at the evolution
of our technology
the printing press brought mass media
the Kinetoscope brought early film
computer circuitry led to animation the
internet and of course videogames we've
always thought news stories yes but also
new ways to tell those stories science
fiction has played an important part in
that process it grants us an escape from
reality where we can see ourselves in
different worlds with different rule
sets it connected a sort of test chamber
or as one of my co-workers recently put
it a petri dish in other words the best
stories in the genre offered insight
into the human condition the author
Jules Verne offered such captivating
sci-fi stories that literary critics
were all but forced to take the genre
seriously work such as 20,000 Leagues
Under the Sea
around the world in 80 days and journey
to the center of the earth had profound
impact on both the literary and the
scientific world the author Ray Bradbury
even went so far as to say we are all in
one way or another the children of Jules
Verne's during the 20th century
so IFI expanded into other fields as
well inspired by several of Verne's
novel French director George Malley A's
released a trip to the moon in 1902 it
was the earliest example of sci-fi and
cinema Fritz Lang's Metropolis widely
considered the first great
feature-length sci-fi film shows us the
city where dictators control the
populace through robotic sutter fuge and
paranoia it's setting doesn't just serve
an aesthetic purpose but a functional
one as well it uses its science fiction
to show the class struggle between the
city's poor inhabitants and upper-class
elite in 1938 the public expressed
widespread outrage after hearing the War
of the Worlds radio broadcast in which
Orson Welles presented an alien invasion
as a series of realistic news bulletins
national media decried the approach
calling it deceptive and its delivery to
the masses it blurs the lines between
fiction and reality the narrative showed
the hysteria and confusion that might
come along with extraterrestrial contact
even more classics emerge throughout the
century each of them offering a
different take on the sci-fi genre their
own distinct ways of telling new stories
2001 a Space Odyssey further
cemented stanley kubrick's genius ridley
scott became a household name with a
lien and Blade Runner perhaps one of the
best films exploring what it means to be
human
then came the matrix the movie that
offered a postmodern look at our
perception of reality and of course we
have Star Wars it's the defining space
opera in one of America's biggest
contributions to pop culture it spawned
TV series novels and teen fiction
national fan conventions and a four-day
annual celebration it's a testament to
how pervasive science fiction has become
but it's not the plots of all these
films that we've grown attached to it's
usually the character names such as
Ellen Ripley Darth Vader neo forever
ingrained in our collective memory
common people who when thrust into
otherworldly situations become heroes
villains or gods along the way it comes
as no surprise then that science fiction
made its way into video games it's a
medium that thrives on escapism and when
combined with the mystery and wonder of
sci-fi that thrill multiplies tenfold
first person shooters pit us against
intergalactic threats strategy titles
grants us control of alien species
horror games challenge us with the
unknown in the dark places of distant
space but in this medium more than
others we can roleplay the heroes and
make our own allies in front of villains
ourselves we can explore distant worlds
with an agency not allowed in other
forms of entertainment maybe that's why
the Mass Effect trilogy rests
comfortably at the pinnacle of sci-fi
video games
[Music]
building on its success with Knights of
the Old Republic developer Bioware
envelops us in a fully realized sci-fi
setting
we're not witnessing the first contact
between humans and aliens as so many
stories explored were dropped into a
milky way where humans have not only
accepted the presence of alien life but
grown accustomed to it the galaxy's
inhabitants have created a Galactic
government they've studied each other's
cultures they've shared technologies to
help or hinder the advancements of their
neighbors which is all to say that Mass
Effect understands what makes sci-fi
great to begin with and wields those
strengths was undeniable force it
acknowledges the difference between
alien races they create characters that
embody and celebrate those differences
they have habits an idiosyncrasy so when
they do do something out of character
it's all the more endearing how are you
getting drunk fairly carefully Tory and
brandy triple filtered then introduced
into the suit through an emergency
induction park that's a straw Ellie say
what you will about Mass Effect 3
controversial ending but the journey
there is filled with moments of mythical
proportions the trilogy takes a diverse
galaxy on the brink of turmoil and uses
its characters to propel the narrative
at almost every turn
that's why Mass Effect Andromeda is all
the more disappointing it's a science
fiction game with massive potential that
it never fully realizes that potential
stems from its tantalizing premise
several groups from the Milky Way
including humans have launched the
Andromeda initiative and attempt to find
habitable planets in the neighboring yet
distant andromeda galaxy
in this case we're the aliens visiting
from a distant world this presents a
slew of narrative opportunities does
this galaxy have sentient life how will
we communicate with them what kind of
wonders or dangers will we encounter
what difficult choices will come with
the burden of our racist survival but
rather than Chaffey storylines any
meaningful direction Andromeda seems
content to guide us through stilted
dialogue boring side quests and lifeless
world this galaxy is gorgeous yes
but there's not much personality here
it's all spectacle and no soul this
should be a story about character
struggling to build a new home after
they've left everything they know behind
for the first several hours Andromeda
characters make only passing comments
about
fact this game constantly tells us that
things are dire but it doesn't Excel
it's showing us as the hours passed we
meet new alien races discover their
motivations and explore new planets that
may or may not be a new home for
Humanity food is scarce and supplies are
dwindling this is a race against time
this should be intense but it doesn't
feel intense we spend hours scanning the
environment and performing menial tasks
we speak to characters with fascinating
backstories but lack luster personality
few things we do create the wonder or
dread that the game tells us we are
supposed to be stealing look at Mass
Effect 2 on the other hand here's a game
that builds expertly torn operation so
daunting so seemingly impossible that
its dubbed the suicide mission only by
gaining your squadmates loyalty and
learning their individual strengths and
weaknesses can you emerge unscathed as a
team and in Mass Effect 2 this process
is thrilling dialogue is captivating
missions carry weight these characters
are painfully human they're lonely yet
strong terrified but brave as you
uncover more of Bioware spellbinding
galaxies you develop very real
attachments to the team
not sure if Torian hasn't is the same as
you all are spun this thing goes
sideways and we both end up down meet me
at the boss I'm by what Mass Effect
Andromeda doesn't deliver the same
experience if characters take too long
to captivate if galaxy is too boring to
pull me through there is a good sci-fi
tale lurking somewhere under the surface
but it's buried by tedium and
frustration an interesting premise is
one thing a well told story is another
mess Effect Andromeda reaches for the
ladder but Falls considerably short yes
it has its shining moments and I'm
hopeful Bioware Montreal can remember
them in any sequel the studio makes but
overall Andromeda remains a
disappointing sci-fi story it lacks the
imagination of the Titans that came
before it it lacks the heart that makes
the best ones memorable
yet if there's anything history tells us
it's that there's always hope for
another great sci-fi adventure as Buzz
Aldrin says in Mass Effect 3 looking up
at that starry sky there are billions of
stars left to explore
[Music]
hey everyone thanks so much for watching
the third episode of reboot jaqen I had
a lot of fun diving into science fiction
this week and as always next Sunday
we'll be doing a reading 3.5 episode
where we filled your comments to
questions you're concerned or
suggestions for future episodes
so get your comments in they might be
featured we'll see you then